oops hello and welcome to this video I
wasn't even aware that i had started the
game ray at stacker care maybe maybe a
French defence oops okay he gifted me a
move here that's nice of him wow wow ok
I want to be ready to answer a 5 with be
5f 6mm let's see I want to make sure not
to fall into a tactic like we should be
3 wood no actually not that isn't a
tactic I've a five so I can't play that
move now have a five okay um yeah Bishop
f4 is not an improvement so let's take
it and now we are probably quindi to
gain a temper with Knight f3 oops oh ok
this is something that I should have
seen really ok sure play 24 which is the
most normal move but yeah simply
overlooked we should be fun ok
and yet detect my rook can it's not easy
here what is this material wise seven
points against voice got three points
now not sure if I'm even better here
maybe I am but it's not it's not totally
clear cut 94 this 25 well ok it's a lot
of big deal i have g3 there ok ok let's
just check the Queen also he's six it's
great 6
I thought that would work but we'll see
I didn't see that d6 is actually
protected but still I can take your
right takes on f3 FB it can take b7 huh
ok so it likes to play rookie to on rook
takes you three so this this seems good
it's two pieces but you can so blind as
I made Queen takes d5 is the idea maybe
I should have done that immediately ok
let's straight trade some material here
okay Queens rate is kind of okay two
pieces up check check ok let's look for
one moment damn squad rogue f7 or
whatever I do okay there is no made
right check check check the snow made
and for should black resigns yeah I made
it more difficult than they needed after
the opening simply didn't see that
Bishop takes before move this is just a
bad idea here yeah this is the the
simplest way to do it when it's
difficult for black even to avoid the
Queen trade but what I wanted to do is
just to to play for an attack now but
yeah like neither three and so on but
Bishop takes before it's just it's just
it's just available now oh here Bishop
c5 would have led into big trouble Wow I
have to play king e tu dois and it's bad
and now things are in order again and
black centers is crumbling him yeah it
was very lucky I didn't didn't see
Bishop takes before it all just played
just played too quickly let move okay
well thanks for watching